actually the last thing I want to show
you that I brought is this on so this is
uh this is a urine wheel that would have
date to the medieval period and so the
idea was that the doctor could diagnose
you according to the color of your urine
spoiler alert if your urines black
you're probably in big trouble yeah
robbed oh yeah and just yeah they didn't
just um look at the color they tasted
the urine as well hilarious so and they
could diagnose diabetes because someone
with diabetes their urine tastes sweet
so they were actually diagnosing
favorite part of of the urine in the
medieval period and doctors with
year.they some some practitioners would
take the urine and put it into a
divination bowl and they could tell your
future and I think they should bring
that back like you know at the end of
your checkup you know not to be covered
by insurance but it you know okay
if they test your urine and you're
totally dehydrated and there's blood in
there like yeah bro you ain't gonna make
well it's weird that image in the the
whole circle the center circle like that
this guy is the doctor holding the flask
yes
is that the doctor yep that would be the
doctor holding the flask and actually
took a wine taster taster I did a whole
on again a youtube video on this which
is why I have this stupid prop and we we
cut through images in that image of the
doctor holding the flask was sort of the
predominant image of a physician up into
a certain period now it's sort of like
the stethoscope is the is the object now
that we associate with doctors but but
for ask you stay urine flasks used to be
it and yeah they're clearing flasks in a
doctors poll yeah Bongo poll and in the
plague mask oh my god but they used to
call them piss prophets because they
they tell your fortune use your urines
oh my god shit i think that is something
we should bring back to bring that back
well you know what if there's tarot card
readers one as prophets yeah at least
piss prophets
basing it on something yeah you know
your urine into that divination bowl I
know there's so many images of the
doctor holding the flask you know
obviously like the car of your urine
could be an indicator of health it still
is okay and look at the guys like what
you think doc the store right now look
at the band-aid around the guy's head
yeah like he's hurt the guy's got a head
injury in the doctor shopping